let's be honest when things are going
badly in-game we all express our
frustrations differently but rage isn't
something that's bound by borders and
languages and if you've ever shared a
gaming lobby with russian-speaking
players you've probably experienced that
firsthand why you don't kick me those
[__] arms rustling mr. reddit
maybe it's the result of decades of
political tomfoolery or being expected
to wrestle bears at the age of five but
to our ultra competitive Kremlin ruled
comrades counter-strike isn't just a
game it's an outlet
yeah although this complaint appears to
be nothing more than an anecdotal
generalization it's hard to deny just
how widespread this characterization has
become over the past 15 years and
perhaps the most iconic tide of this
stereotype is one vulgar phrase in
particular cyka cyka cyka cyka blyat has
been part of the russian language for
hundreds of years so it's nearly
impossible to pinpoint its exact origin
for all we know it might have begun in
the 1600s as an onomatopoeia for
especially violent sneezes or as a
common reaction in Moscow bath houses to
those who are less encumbered what we do
know however is that cyka blyat rose to
prominence alongside counter-strike in
the early 2000s but what the hell does
it even mean well a direct English
translation leads to a number of
different awkward sounding
unpleasantries but according to
political scientists save a good Netsky
it's not actually that straightforward
the first thing to know is that
Americans actually mispronounce it cyka
blyat it's not bled with the tea its
blood with a d-cup lap there is really
no one translation essentially it's
almost a placeholder for whenever
somebody is angry it can mean anything
from um - what the [__] - holy [__] I
can't believe this happened
you can even mean something positive
like I can't believe I just did that I'm
so happy so it's kind of a universal
placeholder for whatever emotion the
player is feeling at the moment context
then is absolutely crucial to
understanding the use of cyka blyat an
encounter strike while variations of the
phrase are occasionally used to express
euphoria what the [__]
but yeah more often than not it's a way
to aggressively articulate frustration
but he be stepping yes you're gonna
think was so Gavin Avenue so why has
cyka blyat risen as the mantra for
Russian players well it might have to do
with MOT the flexible slang system from
which it derives the elegant thing about
math is because every part of speech is
conjugated you can give a shade of
really detailed nuance to every swear
word so there's different ways you can
say [__] like hundred different ways
and each one has a slightly different
meaning which means you can have a very
rich vocabulary of swearing to put it in
perspective you know how we think we
have a lot of synonyms for penis in
English that's nothing compared to
Russians who have upwards of 1200 at
their disposal but why do we encounter
so many raging Russians and matchmaking
well it might be down to the fact that
they're probably counterstrikes most
neglected playerbase think about it all
the major countries and regions where
csgo is actively played have pretty
reliable internet connections and dozens
of their own localised dedicated servers
all of them except for russia sadly for
our ruski brethren they're forced to
matchmake on servers way the [__] over
in sweden
with your closest dedicated server being
potentially thousands of miles away
you're likely to have terrible lag or
shitty ping and for counter-strike
that's a surefire trigger for losing
your mind
on top of latency problems and the
obvious language barrier they're bound
to face with Swedish matchmaking Russian
players are often dropped into na or
other in-you servers where they might
run into this can you [__] speak
English another [__] Russian on our
team yeah Lewton even if you're well
behaved and uninhibited by lag chances
are you'll still be mocked because of
cultural stereotypes perpetuated by the
dregs of your region that's enough to
make anyone a bit salty right for pure
so why doesn't valve do anything to help
these displaced players creating a
dedicated server for Russian players
that's actually in Russia makes a lot of
sense dota 2 has one after all so why
not CS to find out we contacted valve
for an explanation and this is what they
had to say although cyka blyat started
as standard slang within the russian CS
community its popularity as a tool for
ridiculing this player group really took
off in 2015 and 2016 after a number of
compilations and music videos went viral
cyka cyka cyka cyka
cyka cyka cyka cyka cyka with these
videos being watched by millions of
people all over the world the meme was
catapulted into the eSports and
streaming spotlight but cyka blyat reach
extended beyond counter-strike and
engrained itself within Russia's now
dwindling hard base obsessed Gopnik
culture I think the best way to
understand it is it's the Russian
equivalent of jobs in England
it's basically it is a subculture of
young men usually wearing adidas track
suits and if they make a bit of money or
leather jackets and they have cheap
cigarettes and they're drinking cheap
vodka and they're doing the Slavic squat
around the steps of an apartment
building it's kind of faded a bit since
it's heydays of the 90s and 2000's but
it's still very much a residual
subculture in in Russia now as much as I
hate to admit it this scene has produced
some absolute bangers
custom firefighters - you cyka blyat
[Music]
his biggest thing in Europe bro his best
in Europe and even though Gopnik culture
isn't as prevalent as it once was the
opposite is true of cyka blyat which
regularly features during csgo
broadcasts Scout comes out once again
that MDM forced to then play the pistols
as well there we go feels like I'm back
in matchmaking Jesus Christ that's a new
one cyka blyat is both a semi harmless
phrase that evokes laughter over the
aggressive use of a foreign language and
a gross generalization of a culture that
doesn't entirely fit that mold but how
does it impact those that it's come to
represent some people in Russia might be
offended but I can't imagine there are
that many of them I think they would
probably see it as a silly thing that
the West borrowed and uses and I don't
think there's any protest in Russia
about the cultural appropriation of cyka
blyat that's that doesn't seem to me a
particularly potent tool with which to
attack Russian players if nothing else I
think Russian players are more amused by
by this adoption and yeah of course
there's a lot of racism and xenophobia
within some games but yeah I don't feel
like there's a specific anger attached
to Russian players as opposed to
American or any other players I think is
that's jus seems to be a part of the
wider gaming subculture as far as I can
tell and joining me now to discuss this
meme is my Russian colleague Dmitry
Paschal Luda who's currently stationed
in Moscow Dmitriy try to put into words
how you feel about cyka blyat for sure
miles let me depart but I see that
Scully I'm sorry we can't hear you
you're cutting out
classic Russian response to a bad
internet connection a Matt
[Music]
for all we know and I'll read the rest
oh really
[__] hell man get on your bike and
[__] off in it Oh get in the mood talky
a getting a bit chalky in here with the
Kremlin you know what I'm saying but why
do we encounter so many raging Russians
and matchmaking well it may be it might
be it might be day into the fact that
they're bastards [__] that up